FIRST, TRUMP WITH HIS BAD AS
HITLER.
THEN HE WAS WORSE THAN HITLER
NOW HE IS WORSE THAN HITLER AND
STALIN COMBINED.
>> TRUMP IS AS DESTRUCTIVE OF A
PERSON IN THIS CENTURY AS
HITLER, STALIN, AND MEL WERE IN
THE LAST CENTURY.
HE MAY BE RESPONSIBLE FOR MANY
MORE MILLIONS OF US THAN THEY
WERE.
HE NEEDS TO BE CONTAINED BUT HE
NEEDS TO BE CONTAINED BY
ATTACKING HIS POLICIES, NOT HIS
PERSON.
>> YEAH, ATTACK HIS POLICIES,
NOT HIS PERSON.
IT SAYS THIS --
AFTER SAYING TRUMP IS DEADLIER
THAN THREE OF THE BIGGEST MASS
MURDERERS IN HISTORY.
BUT WHY STOP THERE?
WHY NOT ADD ANGUS KOHN, THE
BLACK PLAGUE, ISIS, SYRIA,
CIGARETTES, CLIMATE CHANGE,
MAROON 5?
AND THE ASTEROID THAT WIPED OUT
THE DINOSAURS?
HELL, JUST GO FOR IT, TRUMP IS
RESPONSIBLE FOR MORE DEATHS THAN
DEATH ITSELF.
AFTER SOME OUTCRY CNN ADMITTED
THAT THEY SHOULDN'T HAVE HIT
BACK ADMITTING THEIR MEEKNESS ON
TAX ISSUES WHICH I BELIEVE IF
THE NETWORK HADN'T SPENT THREE
YEARS TRYING THEIR GUESTS FOR
THIS KIND OF HYSTERIA.
>> THE PRESIDENT OF THE
UNITED STATES IS RACIST.
SPEAK ALL THE PEOPLE WHO VOTED
FOR DONALD TRUMP OR RACES.
IF YOU, HE IS A RACIST PIG.
>> RECLAIMING HERITAGE, THAT
SOUNDS A LOT LIKE A CERTAIN
LEADER THAT KILLED MEMBERS OF MY
FAMILY AND ABOUT 6 MILLION OTHER
IN THE 1940s.
>> BROTHER TRUMP IS AT THIS
MOMENT BECOMING THE AMERICAN
VERSION OF HITLER AND MUSSOLINI.
>> JUST LAST WEEK, CNN ACCUSED
TRUMP OF NOT AGING AND SUPER
NATURAL ARGUMENTATION DIRECTLY
RELATED TO AN INHUMAN
CALLOUSNESS AND NOW FOR THE 115
TIME, STELTER BARKS AT THE
FAMILIAR REFRAIN ABOUT TRUMP'S
ERRATIC BEHAVIOR GETTING WORSE.
>> THERE IS DEFTLY WIDESPREAD
RECOGNITION THAT TRUMPS BEHAVIOR
IS GETTING WORSE.
IN TYPE AND INFREQUENCY.
IT SEEMS EXACTLY MORE EROTIC
MORE OFTEN.
WE CAN'T TIPTOE AROUND IT
ANYMORE.
WE'VE GOT TO TALK ABOUT THIS.
>> ONE WAS LAST TIME STELTER WAS
ABLE TO TIPTOE AROUND ANYTHING?
THERE'S GOT TO BE A NEW PHRASE
TO REPLACE JUMPING THE SHARK FOR
CNN.
MAYBE IT'S CALLED LOSING VIEWERS
BY THE BUTLER BECAUSE THE
PROBLEM WITH THE SHRINK'S
OPINION ABOUT TRUMP ISN'T THAT
IT STOOD OUT FROM THIS PACK OF
BRAYING HYENAS BUT THAT IT
DIDN'T STAND OUT AT ALL.
HE WASN'T TRYING TO SHOCK
STELTER, HE WAS AUDITIONING FOR
HIS JOB.
>> Charles: DO I SMELL?
I WAS JUST CHECKING.
I THINK IS NOT THAT I THINK I
MIGHT HAVE A LITTLE BODY ODOR.
I WANT.
TO COME AT 3 MILES.
I'M DISGUSTING.
I SMALL GROSS AND I THINK I'VE
LET EVERYBODY DOWN HERE.
I CAN SMALL MYSELF.
>> USUALLY YOU TELL US IF FOX
AND FRIENDS HAD A FISH BUT I
DON'T SMELL ANYTHING.
I DIDN'T SMALL THEIR FISH, I
DON'T SMELL YOU.
>> WELCOME ALONG, NO PERSON CAN
BE THAT THE EVIL SO IT KIND OF
THROWS THEIR ENTIRE OPINIONS
UNDER THE BUS BECAUSE THEY ARE
SO HYSTERICAL.
UNLESS YOU THINK TRUMP IS WORSE
THAN HITLER, STALIN, AND MOUTH.
>> NO, I DON'T, BUT I'M ALSO NOT
A SHRINK.
I'M NOT A SHRINK SO I DON'T HAVE
ANY OPINION ON THIS BUT I DO
THINK THAT IN TERMS OF WHAT WE
DO, WHICH IS POLITICAL
COMMENTARY, THAT YES, HIS
POLICIES AND HIS WORDS, CAN BE
HURTFUL, THEY CAN BE DAMAGING
AND I WILL SAY SO.
WHEN HE SAID STUFF ABOUT       A
WHEN HE SAID STUFF ABOUT       O
WHEN HE SAID STUFF ABOUT       T
WHEN HE SAID STUFF ABOUT       D
WHEN HE SAID STUFF ABOUT       O
THINK THIS IS LOW QUESTION MIGHT
THAT'S PRETTY WEIRD WHEN HE SAYS
OVER THE WEEKEND, HE SAID OBAMA
LOST THIS I THINK WHAT YOU
TALKING ABOUT?
HE SAID MILANI GOT TO KNOW
KIM JONG UN VERY WELL AND THEY
GOT ALONG COMPLETELY AND SPEND
THE STUFF COMES UP AND SAID NO,
THEY NEVER MET ACTUALLY AND YOU
SAID WHY DID THE PRESIDENT SAID
I?
SO THINGS LIKE THAT MAKE YOU
THINK WELL, IT'S POLICIES AND
HIS WORDS AND ACTIONS THAT ARE
WORTH IT.
>> Charles: WE HAVE KNOWN IT
THREE YEARS TRUMP MAKES THESE
SHAPES TO HELP CREATE A
DIRECTIONAL TRUTH.
LIKE THINGS ARE GETTING BRIGHTER
WITH MELANIA AND WHATEVER BUT WE
ALL GO THERE.
WE GET IT PAID AS NOT BEING
HITLER.
>> KNELT AT I WILL SAY THAT WE
ARE GOING TO GET TO JOE BIDEN
AND NOT KNOWING WHAT YOU ARE
TALKING ABOUT SO THAT'S A LITTLE
RICH TO LEAD WITH TRUMP ON THAT.
I WOULD SAY THE MORE THEY HATE
HIM, THE LESS THEY UNDERSTAND
HANDED THEY CAN'T UNPACK THE WAY
HE TALKS AND WHY HE TALKS THAT
WAY AND THAT HE IS PART
COMEDIAN, PART NEWS CREDIT,
UNFAZED BY THE NORMS AND A
PRESIDENT THAT IS --
THE THINGS THAT NORMAL PEOPLE
REACT TO COME IT IS A RANCH TO
HE DOUBLES DOWN THEM AND
CHALLENGES THEM ON THAT AND HE'S
GOING TO THINK OUTSIDE THE BOX
ON A NUMBER OF ISSUES.
BUT TO THE POINT ABOUT DEATH AND
THE PEOPLE KILLED, HE WANTED
LIKE ABOUT SAVING LIVES, NO ONE
IS HOPING THAT ANYONE PASSES
AWAY BUT IF THERE WERE TO BE ONE
MORE SUPREME COURT JUSTICE, HE
MIGHT JUST NOMINATE THE NEXT
JUSTICE THAT WILL OVERTURN
ROE VS. WADE AND THEN WE MIGHT
ACTUALLY SAVE MILLIONS OF
FOREIGN LIES.
>> WOW.
THAT WOULD BE A WELCOME
DEVELOPMENT IN THIS COUNTRY.
SAVE MORE LIVES THAN ANY
PRESIDENT EVER HAS.
>> Juan: I, MAY BE A WELCOME
DEVELOPMENT IF YOU WANT TO
CIVIL WAR.
>> Charles: I WANT TO BRING IN
DANA BRADY BEEN GONE FOR A
WHILE.
>> Dana: IT HASN'T BEEN THAT
LONG BUT I'M GLAD TO BE BACK AT
ONE OF THE THINGS WE TALKED
ABOUT IS WHY DO THESE YOUNG
PEOPLE THINK THAT SOCIALISM
ISN'T A PROBLEM?
WILL PARLAY IF YOU START TALKING
ABOUT HISTORY AND THE WAY THAT
DOESN'T ACTUALLY ACCURATELY
DESCRIBE WHAT HAPPENED IN
HISTORY, HE WILL WATER DOWN
PEOPLE'S KNOWLEDGE OF IT AND
THEN PRETTY SOON THEY JUST THINK
THAT HITLER WAS SOME GUY AND
THEY ARE JUST LIKE THESE GUYS
FROM HISTORY AS A COMPARISON NOT
ONLY IS IT COMPLETELY UNFAIR BUT
IT ALSO IS DESTRUCTIVE IF YOU
ARE TRYING --
IF YOU CARE ABOUT PEOPLE
LEARNING HISTORY.
>> Charles: ALSO, TO THE D.A.
IDEA OF DIAGNOSING, HE'S A
PSYCHIATRIST.
SHOULD HE BE DISBARRED IN PRISON
FOR LIFE?
>> Dana: I MEAN OKAY, THAT
COULD BE A LITTLE GRAPHIC.
>> ACT AGREE WITH DANA.
THESE ARE USELESS EXERCISES.
COMPLETELY BLUNTING THE ACTIONS
OF OUR PAST.
ANYTHING THAT TRUMP HAS SAID OR
DONE IS NOT PARALLEL TO WHAT WE
HAVE SEEN WITH HITLER, STALIN,
AND MAO BREAD HOWEVER, PETE AND
I TALKED ABOUT THIS TWO YEARS
AGO, THE WHOLE GOLDWATER ROLE
WHEN IT TALKS TO PSYCHIATRIST
COMMENTING ON PUBLIC FIGURES
WHEN I HAVEN'T ACTUALLY TREATED
THEM, IT IS UNETHICAL AND THEY
ARE NOT ALLOWED TO DO IT AND IF
YOU ACTUALLY LISTEN TO THIS
INTERVIEW, IT WAS SO
EMBARRASSING AND RIDICULOUS
BECAUSE HE WAS ACTUALLY SAYING
WE SHOULD NOT BE CRITICIZING
TRUMP.
WE SHOULD NOT BE CALLING HIM
CRAZY BECAUSE THAT IS REALLY
ADDING TO THE STIGMA FOR MENTAL
ILLNESS.
BUT HE SAID THE WORD CRAZY NO
LESS THAN 20 TIMES THROUGH THAT
ENTIRE INTERVIEW AND HE SAID BY
THE WAY, ANYONE WHO VOTES FOR
TRUMP IS CRAZY.
SO HE JUST PLAYED INTO HIS OWN
THING.
IT'S RIDICULOUS.
>> Charles: I HAVE A THEORY.
WHO IN THE MEDIA MOST HELPED
ELECT TRUMPIAN 2016      2016 CS
ELECT TRUMPIAN 2016      2016 CI
ELECT TRUMPIAN 2016      2016 CN
MARKET WASN'T FOX NEWS BUT WE
WERE HAVING OUR OWN INTERNAL
CIVIL WARS ARE OVER CANDIDATES
BECAUSE WE HAD SO MANY TO PICK
FROM AND THE FIVE WAS LIKE A
MICROCOSM OF THAT.
WE WERE ARGUING.
IN A MEDIA THOUGH, CNN AND
MORNING JOE, BOTH, THEY DEVOTED
MOST OF THEIR POLITICAL TIME TO
TRUMP AND NOW THEY ARE HIS
SPANISH INQUISITION IMPAIRED MY
THEORY IS THAT DAY OR TRYING TO
MAKE UP FOR WHAT THEY HAVE DONE
IT BECAUSE THEY ELECTED HIM AND
NOW THEY ARE DOING ALL OF THIS
BECAUSE THEY FEEL TREMENDOUS
GUILT EVEN THOUGH ZUCKER
ADMITTED THAT --
REMEMBER?
MAKE IT A CHARM BECAUSE AND THEN
THEY GOT HIM ELECTED AND THEN --
>> Juan: WE PUT ON HIS RISE,
EVERYBODY PUT ON HIS RALLIES
WITHOUT QUESTION.
>> Charles: WE FOCUS ON ALL
THE CANDIDATES.
>> Juan: NO, I DON'T THINK WE
PUT ON RALLIES FOR JEFF BUSCH
THE WAY THAT WE DID FOR TRUMP.
THEY PUT ON THE BETTER TV.
>> Charles: IT IS VERY
ENTERTAINING.
I DON'T KNOW THAT I FULLY
UNDERSTAND YOUR THEORY TO BE
HONEST.
IT DIDN'T GO OVER YOUR HEAD.
I TAKE THE EXAMPLE OF THE CHOSEN
ONE.
WHERE YOU SAY WELL, I AM THE
CHOSEN ONE AND I WENT NUTS ABOUT
HIM HAVING A MESSIAH COMPLEX
WHEN HE'S MERELY STATING
SOMETHING TO FAMILY THAT IS A
FACT.
PREVIOUS PRESIDENTS HAVE NOT
STARED DOWN CHINA.
IT IS FALLEN RIGHT IN HIS LAP.
HE IS A BUSINESS MAN THAT
UNDERSTANDS THE DYNAMICS AND IS
TAKEN THEM ON.
SPEED TO BE SAID LATER, I WAS
THERE WAS JOKING AND I THINK
THAT THEY HAVE KIND OF LOST
THEIR ABILITY TO HAVE A SENSE OF
HUMOR.
>> Juan: LOOK, WE TALK ABOUT
HIS WORDS BUT WE COULD TALK
ABOUT HIS POLICIES AND
SEPARATING FAMILIES, USELESS
WALL, AND ME AND --
'S BEFORE PEOPLE KEEP BLOCKING
IT IS SEPARATING THAT BEFORE